At the same time as Gloria has been learning about exponential growth to help
her pandas out, Grant has also been trying to figure out exponential functions
to help deal with his company's investments in different bank accounts. Suppose
that Grant wants to invest $10,000 and the bank say, you can get 3% interest
per year compounded yearly. Grant feels confused. The bank explains that
compounded annually means that once a year the total amount of money in the
account is calculated. And then 3% of that amount is added on top of the total
in-, interest. Let's start out by just calculating this for the first three
years that Grant has the account. I've already written in all the information
that we have and really it's all that we need to figure out the rest of this.
You know that he starts out with $10,000 at the beginning of the first year
that he invests. Our interest rate is 3%. So that means that 0.03 times this
amount will be added to the account at the end of the year. 0.03 times $10,000
is 300. 10,000 plus 300 makes 10,300. Since this is the amount that's present
at the end of year 1, it's the amount that's present at the beginning of year
2. So year 2 starts off with 10300. What I would like you to do right now is to
fill in the missing information in each of these cells. How much interest will
he earn in the second year? And how much will that give him at the end of year
2? Use that as the start of year 3 and then calculate the new amount of
interest and then the new total.